les gars je vais aux toilettes quand je
reviens je veux que ce que manger en
question même temps convaincre quelqu'un
sait si tu veux quand je lis vos
commentaires j'entends ce que vous me
dites reprenons ça depuis le début ça va
au lit car oui tout se passe bien très
bien
est-ce que reprenons depuis le début
c'est ma phrase non mais qui dirait
prenons mais et c'est pas juste une
phrase c'est tout un symbole reprenant
depuis début ça paye en oublie ce que tu
crois savoir ça veut dire remet en
question des idées ou alors je veux dire
gros prend un truc depuis le départ toi
tu reprends depuis là où tu en es tu es
et soutien à tout prix à reprendre
depuis le début tu viens sur ma chaîne
youtube et une cravate n'importe quoi
puis tu as déjà un gimmick qui est super
pour lens est évident et autre fois
c'est loïc génériques
oui ça arrive saisir garde loïc
générique fait tuer tout excuser l'aller
puis cuites
reprenons depuis longtemps et 6 en 2010
est dans mon premier livre je vous
expliquer comment réussir à négocier ou
comment réussir un entretien d'embauché
par contre pour l avoir un bouquin
évidemment dans mon deuxième livre je
vous expliquais entre autres comment
réussir à convaincre quelqu'un ou
comment réussir à se faire augmenter
aujourd'hui on passe clairement une
étape avec des situations concret
c'est-à-dire que les techniques que je
vais vous exposer la dans les situations
que je vous expose elles sont
applicables à d autres situations de
votre vie quotidienne
c'est clairement pas vraiment
que ce soit pour un entretien d'embauché
une augmentation ou autres choses la
première chose que vous devez savoir
c'est combien vous valez avoir cette
réflexion en amont ça va vous permettre
de garder le pouvoir et surtout de ne
pas réagir émotionnellement lors des
moments de confrontation patron je peux
voir cinq minutes oui faut cinq minutes
maximum parce que j'ai pas mal de boulot
alors comme vous savez moi je suis
rentré dans la société il ya deux ans et
du coup j'ai gagné en productivité dans
mon travail j'ai compris les objectifs
de la société et je me suis fait former
à de nouvelles compétences
bravo du coup je regarde alors non enfin
si si si regardez moi mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que du coup je je
pensais venir vous voir pour une
valorisation de mes nouvelles
compétences
vous voyez ce bug sur son visage c'est
parce qu'il est en train de digérer
cette nouvelle information si j'avais
utilisé le mot augmentation ça aurait
une valeur négative pour lui il connaît
déjà ce mot il a des phrases toutes
faites pour me contrer alors qu'avec la
reformulation phrase valorisation de mes
nouvelles compétences il est obligé de
considérer ma demande je peux offrir 10
euros de crédit sur la machine à café
oui alors moi je pensais plutôt à une
valorisation de mon salaire vis-à-vis de
ces nouvelles compétences dans le sens
où si j'étais arrivé il ya deux ans avec
cette productivité dans mon travail et
avec ses compétences j'aurais déjà eu un
meilleur salaire dès le départ ou alors
vous ou sur payés pendant deux ans
bien jouer c'est un coup bas mais ça
marche maintenant je vais arrêter
d'argumenter et je vais lui demander de
se justifier ces nouvelles astuces très
efficace excusez moi est ce que vous
pourriez m'expliquer ce qui
m'empêcherait d'avoir une augmentation
au regard de ce que je vous ai exposé
parce que là la société ne peut pas se
le permettre
vous faites un travail formidable mais
n'ont pas les ressources nécessaires
pour vous augmentez lâcheté trop de
bleus attend le coup de grâce maintenant
on va utiliser la troisième astuce c'est
à dire jusqu'où vous êtes prêt à aller
en fait
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à quitter la
société est ce que vous êtes prêts à
tout refuser si jamais vous ont refusé
votre demande
il faut évidemment avoir cette réflexion
là en amont pour ma part je veux faire
preuve de compréhension et de patience
dans la mesure du raisonnable
je comprends tout à fait nous et du coup
je vous remercie déjà pour la
considération que vous faites par
rapport à ma demande et pour les
compliments que vous venez de me faire
sur mon travail je vais je vais réduire
aussi un peu j'ai doublé
je pense qu'avec votre votre accord et
est ce que vous pourriez vous me donner
une date à laquelle ce sera possible
non dans six mois ok est ce que on
pourrait déjà merci beaucoup merci ça
c'est bien parce que si moi moi je peux
attendre six mois
mais du coup est ce qu on pourrait juste
le noter sur un papier quelque chose
dans cette qui formalise un peu la
conversation combien de voix oui j'ai
des goûts mais j'ai déjà pas de stylo
c'est juste là dans votre poche en fait
je vous met sur noir ça sera mieux sur
une feuille blanche mais j'ai vraiment
besoin qu'on formalise cet accord parce
que j'ai besoin de me projeter dans le
temps et si jamais je peux pas avoir cet
engagement ferme sur six mois je suis
obligé d'envisager ma place dans la
société que j'ai pas envie de quitter à
la base parce que je suis très bien ici
avec vous c'est vraiment une passion
vous êtes quelqu'un d'inspirant déjà de
base
donc voilà si on le met par écrit ou je
serais obligé d'envisager un départ
voici donc la progression rapide une
discussion potentiels sachent est ce que
vous valez sachez ce que vous voulez et
fait valider la légitimité de votre
demande si vous ne recevez pas votre
goût instantanément
alors négocier pour plus tard et fait
valider sa part écrit ensuite et si vous
n'avez jamais de ou même pas pour plus
tard alors vous devez savoir si vous
êtes prêt à quitter votre job ou à
rester comme ça dans l'état et cette
réflexion vous devez évidemment la voir
en amont avant d'arriver par simple de
négocier avec son ordinateur
pas évident sauf quand on a une arme
secrète pour récupérer de l'argent sur
ses achats
c'est le principe du cashback et la
meilleure extension pour le faire c'est
igraal qui sponsorise cette vidéo au
passage concrètement y vous rembourse
une partie de vos achats ça c'est le
cash back et sur plus de 1700 sites
différents dont amazon adidas sephora
etc etc igraal c'est un site internet
mais c'est aussi une extension pour
votre navigateur c'est ce que j'utilise
moi mais c'est également une application
pour android ou ios
je vous recommande vivement l'extension
pour votre navigateur parce que comme ça
quand vous naviguez de site en site
quand vous êtes sur un site partenaire
qui fait du cashback l'extension le
détecte et vous vous passez jamais à
côté de votre cash back détail excellent
le cash back se cumulent au coupon de
réduction que vous pourriez avoir aux
bons d'achat tous les autres trucs comme
ça pour gagner de l'argent donc à la fin
je pense t on se débrouille dans on peut
gagner pas mal
c'est bien je vous fais voir rapidement
un exemple concret dit graal de comment
recevoir votre cash back
donc je vais aller acheter quelque chose
sur un site gens n'importe lequel là je
vais mettre sur amazon mais j'aurais pu
aller autre part où j'aurais pu d'abord
cherché en amont sur le site quels
étaient les sites partenaires mais bon
quand je vais sur amazon je sais que mon
extension se déclenche voilà et que là
je valide le cash back
donc je fais mes petites emplettes je
rajoute tout ça je vais voir dans mon
panier
voici le montant total est là ce qu'il
va se passer c'est que maintenant amazon
va reverser une commission et igraal et
i gr dvas me reverser une partie de
cette commission c'est ça le cash back
c'est utile c'est sécurisé et on peut
même s'en servir pour réserver un voyage
par exemple donc sur les gros montants
ça devient encore plus intéressant dans
quelques jours à peine je pourrais voir
se cache bag revenir vers moi c'est un
petit peu magique
voilà ça c'est ce qu'on peut appeler une
bonne négociation avec son ordinateur
si vous téléchargez igraal du moins si
vous vous inscrivez en passant par le
lien qu'il ya dans ma description vous
allez en plus touché un bonus de 10
euros départ au lieu de 3 euros en temps
normal oui là aussi il ya une
négociation
merci graal négocié avec son copain ou
sa copine négocier avec un pote et de la
petite négociation de vie quotidienne on
fait plein en permanence deux astuces à
appliquer ne cherchez pas à recevoir
quelque chose si vous n'avez rien à
donner en échange
et puis ne jamais rester sur un nom
romain tu fais quelque chose rien du
tout cool je peux te parler deux
secondes battant que c'est pas pour nous
demander quelque chose ça aussi c'est
important vous devez choisir le bon
moment le bon mode pour négocier tous
les moments ne sont pas bons pour ça
soyez vigilants tu sers au mcs
concernant ma soirée d'anniversaire mon
costume de bob l'épongé rigole il ya des
trucs auxquels on ne touche pas ça c'est
la base c'est sacré et non j'ai juste
une galère je peux pas le faire chez moi
du coup je me demandais si on pouvait le
faire chez toi alors lancé moore fabien
non non non il n'y aurait pas trop de
monde tu connaîtrais tous les invités
non non c'est trop petite où ça va être
le bordel à kalou abarth plus tôt non
mais non en fait l'idée c'était au
contraire de faire une soirée un peu
posé jeux de société à la cool tu vois
et si tu veux en moi en contrepartie le
lendemain je deviens tu un homme de
ménage
je te clean ton appart roma comme jamais
en te la clean et ouais ouais je sais
pas non ça va être galère mais je
comprends mais à la limite
dis moi ce qu'il faudrait pour que tu
dises oui et je règle le problème
je sais pas baky et 15 personnes max que
personne dans chez moi ça c'est niet
personnes touchent aux costumes de bob
du coup voilà on touche pas et tu fais
ça à vendredi et tu t'occupes de tous à
prévenir les voisins tout normal c'est
tout à fait normal je m'occupe de tout
ça comme tu as demandé est un pote en or
et tu es tu je t'invite également à mon
anniversaire du web chez moi je vais
dormir chez moi aussi non ça c'était un
condensé de conversation mais vous avez
vu comment j'ai placé la contrepartie
pour transformer le nom en oui essayez
toujours de savoir ce qu'il faudrait
pour transformer le non en oui et régler
le problème
il ya plein de 90 dans votre vie ou
quelqu'un aura d'ascendant sur vous ça
peut être votre coach votre mère ou
n'importe qui d'autre qui a une
compétence supérieur à vous dans un
domaine particulier
même entre potes l'ascendant change de
personnes suivant le domaine dans lequel
vous êtes en train d'évoluer prenons un
exemple avec la mer fictive assez moi ta
mère oui pour le rôle c'est le rôle que
tu me donnes je joue tamer
merci non mais tu symbolise ma mère oui
bah ça va super sympa le ton que
j'aurais dit avoir abandonné sens où bon
bah du coup excuse moi mais là c'est un
rôle de composition ce témoin éloigné de
moi je vais avoir besoin d'accessoire
j'ai pas avoir un truc non mais pas
besoin de terrain tu correspond très
bien au losc us - non mais tu t'es très
bonne comédienne équipe s poursuit
c'était pour l'exemple
pour cette astuce là on aura besoin de
trois points particuliers en premier la
personne qui a une compétence supérieu
re à vous va avoir tendance à vouloir
prendre soin de vous et donc elle va
s'inquiéter
donc la première chose que vous avez à
faire c'est de vous mettre à la place de
cette personne pour anticiper ces
craintes et pouvoir la rassurer
imaginons que vous souhaitiez faire un
achat ou une sortie et que vous
demandiez à votre mère encore une fois
ne focalisez pas sur cette personne là
précisément les techniques sont
applicables à d'autres personnes donc
voici un exemple qui est pris
complètement mais alors complètement
complètement complètement au hasard
tu sais concernant la tournée de fabian
lucas mange j'aimerais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup aller à son spectacle
mais là c'est quoi sont encore c'est un
mentaliste que je suis sur youtube au
saut valley merci merci
non mais attends le mec sur scène il
parle du cerveau il a écrit plein de
livres sur le sujet et ça c'est son
troisième spectacle je crois et et tu
verras c'est drôle et intéressant en
même temps vous voyez là je viens de la
rassurer sur les deux mots qui lui font
le plus peur à sa part mentalist et
youtube maintenant le but c'est de
trouver comment la faire basculer vers
le oui il ya toujours une ouverture pour
ça donc le but maintenant c'est lui
demander et le plus simple c'est de
demander
franchement non mais je rêve le mec
apprend aux gens à négocier pour venir
voir son propre spectacle
si ça c'est pas un escroc de tous les
temps non mais tu sais c'est un
spectacle tout public et je suis sûr que
tu vas aimer ça et du coup c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse pour
que je dise oui pour que je dise oui ah
bah tiens ça c'est bien à 11 ans et bien
déjà que détient que tu mettes ce
week-end et nettoyer tout le garage est
un chambre si qu'elle reste clean
complètement clean parce que là c'est le
bazar trop me promit promis promis
promis promis je fais tout ça du coup
c'est bon on y va on verra
ne vous braquez pas c'est là
qu'intervient la troisième technique un
bonus pour la faim dans une négociation
il ya toujours un moment un point de
bascule donc garder sous le coude un
argument ou un élément fort que vous
allez utiliser quand la personne sera
prête à me dire oui mais c'est pas
encore pour finalement la faire basculer
tu sais l'année dernière il a même joué
son spectacle à l'olympia et à la fin il
ya toujours des dédicaces où ils restent
là pour voir les gens et tout et en plus
je m'étais dit que si tu aimé le
spectacle et je suis sûr que tu fais
mais je te promets et bien la fin moi
j'avais envie de tout acheter le livre
et tu pourrais être le faire dédicacer
ce sera pour la manipulation quand les
sentiments ça si mais c'est de la
négociation sans mensonges et sans
manipulation négative donc en fait c'est
ça m'est donc tu me demandes d'acheter
des places pour ton propre spectacle
c'est ça enfin nous on sait pas assez et
hélas pas vraiment mon spectacle
parce que là c'est pas vraiment moi pas
vraiment de toi maintenant oui donc
numérique les appâts s'cusez moi j'veux
pas vraiment amer et non c'était très
gênant c'est très bizarre
oui bon donc du coup jour là cette merde
là hein tu vois que tu préfères et wau
le matin mais pas du tout écoute un
moment donné tu me donnes pas leur
donnèrent merde pilote à la limite bon
toute façon ils ont pris l'exemple là
non voilà
que ce soit un professionnel ou un
particulier qui vend quelque chose en
général quand on dit le mot négociation
on pense à la relation acheteurs
vendeurs et les pouvoirs sont en général
bien répartie ya quelqu'un qui veut
vendre absolument quelque chose il ya
quelqu'un qui veut absolument obtenir
quelque chose
la première des trois astuces et d'avoir
du temps il va falloir prendre le temps
de s'intéresser à l'autre d'argumenter
de discuter de réfléchir en gros si vous
n'avez pas le temps
ne cherchez pas à négocier milan
renseignement oui s'il vous plaît oui ok
je m'intéresse à la télévision numéro
314 que j'ai vu en wagon lol ouais ça
excellent choix mais je peux même vous
présenter d'autres modèles sous l'oeil à
biot non en fait j'ai pas vraiment
besoin de change était déjà de base une
belle télé ya quelques années mais elle
fonctionne très bien aujourd'hui mais là
en me baladant celle ci elle m'a
accroché parce qu'elle a un peu ouvre
quand même mais j'ai pas vraiment besoin
en même temps je me dis est ce que je me
sépare et pas de l'ancien pour celle ci
en même temps ça coûte pas mal de sous
quand même
c'est parti je viens de me mettre dans
la position inverse de la technique
précédentes ce père que là c'est moi qui
ai besoin d'arguments pour qu'ils me
fassent basculer
je viens en réalité de lui faire perdre
un petit peu de son pouvoir en mettant
en avant la notion d'argent je comprends
d après vous gagnerez en qualité par
rapport à votre matériel actuel la gdt
les cds ultra ultra je sais combien
définition alors on est sur du doubs ce
qu il fait simplement de ne pas
comprendre ce que je dis mais c'est
normal parce qu'il joue sa partie
évidemment mais moi la ccl en fait c'est
pas une dépense nécessaire dans ma vie
j'ai pas budgétisé ça du coup pour que
ça rentre dans mon budget il me faudrait
une réduction de 15 20 % et on quitte à
payer en plusieurs fois
ce projet est possible
j'ai en train de préparer la troisième
technique faire des concessions parce
qu'en fait de personnes qui négocient
ces deux personnes qui font des
concessions chacune de leur côté mais
moi en tant qu'acheteur jusqu'à
maintenant j'avais rien n'a concédé mais
ça ça va changer et 15 1% car mon bon
vous êtes cash
je vais te caches c'est possible à la
haye et à la rigueur je peux faire quoi
ces 5% et en corse où vous prenez un peu
plus de matos est aujourd'hui non mais
je comprends mais à un moment donné moi
j'ai pas une enveloppe qui extensible à
l'infini si j'ai déjà du mal à acheter
cette télé je peux pas acheter des
choses en plus mais en même temps elle
m'intéresse mais pas à ce prix
à la limite ce que je peux faire c'est
m'organiser pour tout payer en une seule
fois aujourd'hui première concession
avec mise en avant de l'élément bloquant
tout à l'heure j'étais peut-être
intéressés et encore si je pouvais payer
en plusieurs fois
maintenant je suis intéressé c'est sûr
et je veux payer en une fois j'ai
commencé à concéder et apporter des
choses
ok ouais bon faut que je vois si
exceptionnellement aujourd'hui on peut
pas vous faire les 5% sans multi achats
après si on regarde les choses un peu
différemment vu le prix de la télé c'est
un peu comme si j'avais acheté 10
imprimantes en une seule fois et là
j'aurai une bonne réduction pour un
achat comme ça c'est quand même très
conséquente 15% ça me paraît raisonnable
c'est impossible je peux faire mais le
max que je puisse faire c'est me % si
vous prenez la carte finit-il meilleur
hockey eh ben je vais la prendre mais du
coup on fait comme ça et moi je
m'organise du porcien samba merci pour
ce bon
mes dernières concessions ont été de
réduire la réduction justement que je
demandais et d'accepter de prendre la
carte de fidélité
alors encore une fois tout ça c'est très
schématique et je vous ai fait voir des
astuces pour n'ont pas payé le prix le
moins cher possible mais le prix le plus
juste
vous auriez pu aussi préparer des
alternatives à votre négociation mais ça
ça nécessite également d'y penser en
amour la dernière astuce que je dois
vous donner c'est celle du choix unique
vous ne pouvez pas négocier sur
plusieurs tableaux en même temps par
exemple pour le vendeur de télévision je
pouvais pas et négocie le prix de la
télévision et essayer d'obtenir
l'assurance cinq ans gratuite
vous devez savoir à l'avance la chose
unique que vous voulez négocier
je sais pas d'ailleurs ce que vous
pensez de cette manière de filmer les
mentale keeps derrière de deux de mettre
en scène un petit peu les as tu sais ce
que c'est plus clair pour vous pas avec
des comédiens dit dites moi j'attends
vos retours en parlant des comédiens
merci beaucoup à eux d'être venus ils
sont tous sur youtube
ils font tous de l'humour en vidéo mais
des manières et des sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir vous invite à les découvrir
les liens sont à la description il ya
céline âge là romain henry la maxe bird
et ya jérémy credeville aller voir leurs
chaînes découvrez leur travail
et puis dites moi donc les retours
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce genre de
format de nouveaux formats d une équipe
d'ailleurs équipe qu'on a pu avoir grâce
à ea kral merci beaucoup à israël doit
par sponsoriser la vidéo n'oubliez pas
que vous avez 10 euros au lieu de 3
euros offerts en passant par le lien qui
est dans la barre d'infos
à très bientôt ciao